you're saying that in 2007 there was a
moment where you were almost trading for
Kobe yeah I thought it was gone please
tell me that story I was in Dancing with
the Stars I was going back and forth
with Dr Buss I think he called me
actually and said look we think we might
be partying ways with Kobe I remember it
vividly because there was a PA named
Elvis who was working on it was just
Lakers Lakers Lakers Lakers Lakers I
used to give him a hard time he'd give
me a hard time and we had just gone to
the finals the year before so it started
to happen I started telling him about it
the minute I told Elvis it all fell
apart I guess Mitch cup check talked
Kobe into stain Dirk was like I would
have traded me for Kobe and I'm like no
I'm not going to trade you Dirk that's
the whole point right wow yeah we would
have been something else